This is gonna be good.
Do we really
have to do this?
Yes, we're not
communicating.
We need help.
We're not
communicating?
Yeah, we're not
communicating.
I don't even know what
you're saying right now.
(door opens)
Hello.
Hi, I'm Chrissy Teigen.
I'm so sorry
about the wait.
Come on in.
Thank you so much
for seeing us.
No problem.
It's gonna
be fine.
So let's get started.
First of all, how long
have you two been together?
Four years.
Well, we had a good run,
if that's what you mean.
Well, I think it's great
you guys are both here.
It shows that
this relationship
is something that's important
to the both of you.
I'm sorry,
aren't you a model?
She's a supermodel.
You sound like a real
ass(bleep) right now.
I actually was a model,
but now I'm a clinical
social worker
and I really love it.
You know, I'm really
enjoying this now
and I mean, who wants
to ride a horse naked
for the camera
all the time?
I'd rather just
do that on my own.
And as you know, modeling
is great,
but you hit 27
and suddenly, you're old.
Oh, that's not old.
Amy's 37.
I'm 32.
Yeah, but you're
a drinker.
All right, so let's talk about
what brought you two here.
I'll start.
Um...
You know, when,
when Amy gets jealous,
I get really
frustrated.
So I have to like,
you know,
go to the gym and then
I gotta sweat it out.
Just... (growls)
And Amy?
Well, I, I feel like
he's cheating on me.
You just need to learn
to believe that I'm not.
Uh, well, these sound
like two very conflicting
perspectives, obviously--
Can you put your glasses
back on, please?
Of course.
Thank you.
No, no.
No, no, no.
No,
don't do that.
Okay, uh, well, he never has sex
with me, like at all.
It's because
I don't want to.
And Amy, how does
that make you feel?
That makes me feel unattractive,
Chrissy Teigen.
You know what, Kevin,
maintaining self-esteem
for a woman
can be really difficult.
I think we all feel
a little bit ugly sometimes.
All right, I want
to try a role play.
I'm going to be Amy.
Kevin, I'd like you
to say to me
all the things that you'd
like to do to Amy in bed.
Okay--
No.
I don't think that's
a good idea for us--
First, I want to kiss
you for hours.
And then I want
to run my fingers
through your long,
dark hair.
And then
I wanna drive you crazy
by licking you in places
no other man,
including John Legend,
has ever touched
before.
All right,
why don't you now
say those things
directly to Amy?
It's okay.
I think she got it.
I don't think
this is helping at all.
So it's agreed.
We're on a break.
You know what I like
to do sometimes is kind of
finish off the session
with just one of you.
I think that would be
the smartest deal here.
Okay, yeah.
Amy, you'll take
a Citi Bike home, right?
I've never even used
a Citi Bike.
It's really easy.
You just use a credit card.
Actually, Kevin, I think it's
best if I finish with Amy,
but, um, you know what?
My business cards
are still being made.
But all my information
is on this for you.
Oh, my God.
Thank you.
We have a calendar--
Wow,
this has everything.
I will put this
to use.
Great, and then
I will see you Monday.
Monday.
Perfect.
I will see you then.
Monday.
See you at home.
See you.
Girl,
don't blow this, girl.
What?
That man out there
is a total catch.
You need to lock it down.
Really?
(phone chimes)
Oh, gross.
It's a dick.